you sure it doesn't say free Palestine
you sure are we positive about that I'm
fascinated by white people who love
getting tattoos of [__] they can't read
you don't know what that says that could
say I'm a dumb [__] and you would have
no idea what's my name I know it's it's
obviously means something but if I ask
you to not look at your forum and write
your name in Arabic whatever that was
you'd be
like can I Google it you have never fact
checked that tattoo never once did you
look at and be like yo how do you say my
name in Arabic and make sure it lines up
somehow we just let white girls do that
I'm like oh that's what they do are you
from here she's German oh so that's I'm
not racist tattoo I got you Germans
they're still apologizing for that 1938
[__] they got to constantly let you know
they like Jews I'm surprised you went
[__] Arabic honestly that might be a
little bit anti-semitic now that I think
about it what ises that you should
that's your name